there's been a lot made with good reason
about how well they made you look not
like you mm-hmm what I'm wondering I'm
curious if you think there is a version
of destroyer without that without
personal prosthetics and them in the wig
if there was if the movie could be done
if you had just sort of been looking
like yourself in both timelines I think
it's really tough to actually say that
the answer is yes because the wonderful
thing about Nicole that distinguishes
her not just from many people but even
from other actors is how she understands
the value of taking care of herself
you know she you you you sleep enough
you're aware you're you try a sound
screen you work facials you know but but
you but you I meditate you meditate you
do the stuff that this character never
does and she wears her sleeplessness her
stress for anxiety her shame all of that
is a part of who she is and I don't
think we get away clean when when we're
suffering from so many of those burdens
I'm wondering how the the all the the
extra that the prosthetics the the wake
how that factors into your performance
how do you use it is it something you
think about or is it something you sort
of just meld into meld into you know
from what I come from where I'm always
trying to and yes I probably could have
played the role looking like myself and
just had to you know just wear
absolutely no makeup and just your hair
pull back and but I'm not sure that it
would have been as believable I just
think that's where you and there's
something about going move away from the
wonderful thing as an actor is having
the chance to change your physical
identity
because the physical identity is
confining it just is and can you do it
without doing that you should absolutely
be able to do it but it is a visual
medium and is there a way in which you
can use both the internal and the
external to really try and support an
audience yeah I think there is what
fascinated me I think the most about
both the character and the performance
is is her voice yeah I was wondering how
you develop that because it almost sort
of so impressive how you always sounded
like you were straining like I always
sound like you had just spent a night
screaming I wonder yeah I'm wondering
how you developed that my voice just was
shot you know I I do it's a you know
certain sort of exercises to get it to
become a really really hoarse and then
I've got the flu and then I lost my
voice like literally lost my voice and I
was struggling to speak and that was
through the course of the film so the
whole we think real life collided with
they've been a fantastic life and and
also I think I just was manifesting
because of the just the way in which I
was feeling and living at the time I was
not happy making the film I was really
it was it was rough and I was tired and
I was beaten down and all of those
things as an actor I usable mm-hmm so
rather than try to clean them all up
it's like you just go with it
mm-hmm and I'd love to know the
experience of casting Nicole Kidman and
then watching her sort of disappear in
front of you into the performance I mean
it's the it's part of the magic of
making movies and I'm I always approach
each movie a little bit like it's
with some superstition and with the
sense that there is if the movie is
working a special kind of Voodoo to it
that I can't quite control or name or
define and when Nicole walked on set
that first day I knew the Voodoo was it
play and I felt like I just had to take
care of it and make space for it
anything and and without you know giving
anything away I was I was surprised at
how how this this movie plays with time
it plays a structure in the film plays
with that linear storytelling yes was
that though is the case or is that
something that developed and and if it
was always the case why do you think
that's that's key to the way this movie
well it was always the case it was
always on the page that this the film
was structured in that way and I think I
think what we're trying to do is tell a
story about people who can't let go of
the past and who start to in living with
so much shame and regret that hasn't
been dealt with or or accounted for they
sort of live this character Aaron bell
kind of lives between the past and the
present and so in telling a story that
had a lot of circles in it we were able
to sort of see how she lives in this
circle vicious circle in some respects I
was I was really interested in in just
the over the the way violence is
presented in this movie it just feels
very real and very like it's not pretty
yeah I think in this movie is very
pretty yeah I'm wondering for both of
you what that what that meant on set
with that how you wanted to present
physical violence how you wanted to
present the active of giving as good as
you get and things like that how you
wanted to present the violence in the
fact I think it was really important
that it feel real and authentic and not
superhero no no the damage from it is
image I mean I ultimately but deeply
damaged by it so and it had to be rough
and tough and yeah nothing like the
brutality of it yeah is also part of
because we were shooting fast and we
were trying to do and we had this done
coordinate of it a lot of times we're
just like on the fly trying to make
things work and that helps you know but
to see two women fight like that I mean
that's that's great to see that it
happens you just don't get to see it
that often right and it's interesting
that I mentioned that you sort of if
your character spends a lot of time
getting beat up but you're also giving
as good as you get and wonder it has an
actor if it's if it's tougher to to
display violence or display basically is
it is it easier to display getting your
ass kicked or kicking ass probably
getting it's it's hard getting beaten
because and also the way in which I work
and I wish I was better at it is I take
some of the hits and so I'm I and I try
not but there's that fear of oh my gosh
I'm actually gonna get really hurt now
and and I have been really hurt doing
doing certain sequences and particularly
Risa because I did a lot of a lot of it
and because our lives and then in this
film so I've had a lot of very human
fight scenes where they're not superhero
scenes and people are throwing each
other around and a lot of that is you
kind of do have to throw each other
around you learn to take Falls and
everything but I'm not highly
experienced at that so
I just kind of throw myself into it and
hope for the best probably not the best
way of doing it well I think in this
case it turned out thank you guys so
much
[Music]